[Música]
aquí tenía 10 años estoy con mi hermana
y mi abuelo colette pensó varias veces
en deshacerse de sus álbumes familiares
y me pregunté si seleccionar mis fotos
pero decidí no elegir esto es lo que me
tocó vivir
incluso en situaciones extremas hay
momentos felices no es incompatible
esta parisina de 44 años fue violada por
su padre desde pequeña y durante varios
años creo que todo comenzó cuando yo
tenía cuatro años o quizás antes no lo
tengo claro pues la dominación del
abusador se va imponiendo poco a poco
nets
en mi casa había un ambiente incestuosos
mis padres se paseaban desnudos nos
besaban en la boca y eso era aceptado
como normal el nudo más es ahora bus 2 a
7 o consumir padre incluso se mostraba
desnudo cuando tenía una erección de
acuerdo perfectamente
sí colette duda es porque como muchas
víctimas de insectos sufrió una amnesia
profunda la mente prefiere olvidar para
evitar un sufrimiento insoportable hace
2 años recuperó la memoria cuando su
hijo le contó que su abuelo el abusador
se luchaba con el salir de la iglesia
porque estaban mis hijos y porque no
quería que la historia se repitiera
cuando se sale de amnesia los recuerdos
no vienen todos juntos y uno no ve todo
claro desde afuera un huevo tutla ser
canción eso es lo difícil de la amnesia
traumática tiene un doble filo aceptando
un bloqueo so se está entonces que salva
pero a la vez te hace prisionero
colette se armó de valor y habló con sus
padres como ocurre muchas veces la
acusaron de haber perdido la razón y la
amenazaron ella cortó toda relación con
su familia
para poner palabras a lo vivido asiste
regularmente a un grupo de conversación
junto a otras víctimas y parientes de
víctimas para todos sin excepción fue
difícil ser escuchados por sus familias
el tema sigue siendo un tabú
cuando mi hermana me contó todo llame a
mi mamá para que nos ayudara ella estaba
cocinando y nos daba la espalda no decía
nada luego le dijo a mi hermana
si esto duró tanto era porque te gustaba
para mí fue demasiado
estar frente a una persona vivir todo de
nuevo uno siente el juicio de los otros
la desconfianza la persona no te cree es
horrible y vivir eso y cuando es alguien
cercano es horroroso si es nueva secuela
yo tenía cuatro años mi padre acababa de
abusar de mingus yo subí a ver a mi
madre que estaba con mi hermana pequeña
y me dijo no estoy disponible para ti
él me respondió
en algunas familias este silencio dura
muchos años pues el incesto se repite
por generaciones una espiral de la que
el grupo familiar no puede escapar
mi abuela murió al dar a luz mi abuelo
no se volvió a casar
entonces abusó de mi madre hasta que
ella tuvo la menstruación le hicieron
ver que no era posible que podía quedar
embarazada es hereditario de baja gnoffo
brooks ahora es una historia de familia
hace algunos días supe que una tía fue
violada durante años por un hermano
mayor y como su mamá le pidió no decir
nada y como toda la familia lo sabía
a todos los que quisieron hablar nadie
les creyó seguimos repitiendo la
historia y cada vez que se sabe algo
nuevo hacemos como si fuera la primera
vez y le bajan el perfil los maldigo
según una encuesta de noviembre pasado
un 10% de la población francesa dice
haber sido víctima de abuso sexual en su
infancia el 80% son mujeres y las
estadísticas podrían ser peores ya que
muchos no denuncian
desgraciadamente uno piensa que esto
pasa en las familias de menos recursos
entre personas vulnerables o sin
educación es algo que ocurre a todos los
niveles incluidas las familias más
acomodadas donde reina la ley del
silencio yo vengo de una familia
burguesa con recursos y esta no era la
imagen que dábamos a los demás
si las violencias sexuales se producen y
reproducen en el seno familiar es porque
el insecto se da en un esquema de
dominación para el menor
es muy difícil oponerse a la autoridad
de un padre o de un pariente mayor
el psiquiatra yang lópez es terapeuta en
el instituto de victimología allí la
mayoría de las consultas es por incesto
y ese control psicológico es una suma de
estrategias para poner al otro bajo
dominación la seducción las amabilidad y
cuando un niño está bajo dominio puede
incluso tomar partido por su agresor
hace poco algunos hablaban de incesto
con amor no creo que sea como para le
das a esta nube
cada vez más la palabra de las víctimas
se liberan y uno de los grandes tabúes
franceses se desvanece en la universidad
de asas en parís pese a la pandemia
psicólogos abogados y militantes se
reunieron para debatir
sí sí
[Música]
el objetivo hacer evolucionar la ley
sobre incesto y consentimiento para
facilitar el juzgamiento de los
agresores la impunidad es casi la regla
de los delitos de incesto en francia
sólo un 10% de las víctimas denuncia y
de esos casos sólo un 10% termina en una
condena por violación del agresor
lo que desmotiva a las víctimas en la
manera en que las trata el sistema llega
a la comisaría y varias personas
circulando la misma oficina y tiene que
explicar su violación va a estar tensa
porque ha esperado un tiempo antes de
denunciar le van a preguntar por qué no
lo hizo antes además la lentitud de los
procesos no estimula demasiado tengo una
clienta que denunció hace seis años y
todavía está en la investigación
preliminar y eso que el agresor su tío
ya fue condenado a 12 años por haber
violado a sus hijos
la justicia francesa sigue privilegiando
la voz del adulto frente a la del niño
la ley permite a las víctimas denunciar
hasta los 48 años es decir 30 años
después de su mayoría de edad
colette tiene aún cuatro años por
delante pero para ella la mayor justicia
ya está hecha salir de la amnesia y
mirar al fin a su padre como un criminal